on this episode of raised by wolves
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god holy crap everybody or for you
non-believers out there the non-holy
kind
we have two awesome new episodes of
raised by wolves number four
probably being my favorite so far and
there are a ton
of cool theories and things to uncover
like who exactly is under that helmet
i've heard worse the mysterious
inhabitant only known as the host
and who can forget this giant polyhedron
and yes i haven't used that word since
grade 10. but before we get into it make
sure to like and subscribe so you're
notified as soon as one of my raised by
wolves videos
drops paul is right where we left him
having fallen down one of those
giant serpent holes in episode 3. he was
following tally one of the first
generation kids who had apparently
fallen down a similar hole years ago
this seems to be a hallucination as both
paul and the androids have visions of
her
but how is it that androids hallucinate
her they're not
human they can't really hallucinate
unless someone is perhaps
hacking their system and who do we know
is a master hacker
champion sturgis mother and father's
creator paul at this point still has his
locator in him maybe that was used to
hack him or
maybe there's more to paul than we
realize we don't know much about his
upbringing just that his parents
wouldn't talk to him kind of like mine
is it possible he's an android or
perhaps part android could it be that
the show was misdirecting us to believe
campion is the mithraic prophet talked
about in episode 1
but that it's actually paul in fact paul
brings up the prophet in episode three
the pentagonal prophecy an orphaned boy
in an empty land
paul is technically an orphan boy in an
orphaned land
the name paul is also one of jesus's 12
disciples
a disciple who famously went from
non-believer to believer mother ends up
saving paul looking down at this red
glow at the bottom of the hole which
kind of reminds me of that warm red glow
that emanates from the polyhedron
before she finds him she stumbles upon
these hibernation pods used on the ark
we saw them briefly in episode 2. mother
will later come back to this arc finding
the same exact doll
paul found in the forest in episode 3.
she'll hook herself
up to the machine accessing the
simulation which looks like it
too has been hacked since it unlocks
memories some of which were archived by
campion sturgis
someone is wanting mother to get to that
sim someone is wanting her to see those
memories and i think it's this person he
or she doesn't have a name yet marcus
simply refers to it as the
host the host lives in a booby-trapped
serpent skeleton and has been on this
planet for a long time
keeping watch over the settlement the
mithriak find these cards
sperm family five starred symbols
whether these are from the crash or have
been here for years are unknown but
judging by how fast this thing parkours
its way out of there it's likely not
human i'm gonna say this is an android
perhaps even an android version of
champion sturgis
the last name sturgis comes from the old
norse words for
thor and pledge so we have a creator
named after a god
episode 5 where we see the origin story
of mother kind of sets up a little
romance between her and sturgis so
having him return
even with the memories of this past life
opens a lot of story potential
the real sturgis has likely passed the
show makes an effort to show him
multiple times
sick and coughing also putting on a mask
leading me to believe he may have had
some sort of radiation poisoning from
the war on earth the mathrake in their
search for the missing children stumble
upon this giant polyhedron in the middle
of the desert justina over here remarks
how it has five points and she begins to
recite scripture that the
structures in the holy land will provide
them with answers to the mithraic
mysteries
perhaps this is part of the pentagonal
prophecy penta meaning five
we aren't exactly sure what these
mithraic mysteries entail
probably why they're called mysteries
but it likely has something to do with
the mysteries of the universe the
meaning of life all that kind of stuff
the structure gives off heat which they
say is the power of soul coming from the
inside this heat was also seen coming
from those giant holes could this
structure be somehow connected to those
giant serpents
and did the planet once house many of
these as evidenced by the multiple holes
throughout the world
regardless ambrose says this comes from
an intelligent civilization he'll later
give the order to blow the structure to
gain access to its heat
something marcus uses to his advantage
to overthrow him
ambrose will burn to death next to the
heat a sign marcus says is soul's will
and this is good news for him and sue
ambrose basically found out they're not
believers when he recited a mithraic
children's lullaby
something almithraec would know and she
had no idea what it was
it's here marcus claims to hear the
voice of saul is it really saul or is it
something
hacking him regardless the mithraic bow
downed him as their new leader and they
continue their search for the missing
children mother has melted down the
children's methac emblems to create a
scalpel
something she'll use to remove the
location trackers implanted in their
feet
we'll also see her healing powers here
this same scalpel will be used by tempus
to kill the creature and is also found
in marcus's hallucination at the end of
episode 5.
is this one of seoul's visions that is
foreshadowing something that will happen
in the future
we see sue covered in stab wounds by
that scalpel and marcus's head
covered in this helmet the same helmet
we find attached to the prisoner
in the back half of the ark wreckage
this is otho his name isn't mentioned in
the episode but it's there in these
subtitles and
credits he was convicted of sexually
assaulting young women while they were
in hibernation
i can't say the r word or else youtube
will demonetize me
otho is the same person who impregnated
tempest a heliodromus or the second
highest rank in the mithraic religion
he said he was told by seoul to
impregnate these women but as soon as he
was captured seoul's voice
never came back to him seoul seems to be
a puppet master using people and tossing
them aside when they don't suit his or
hers purpose
that could explain marcus's vision he'll
be corrupted by soul who perhaps will
make him kill
sue leading to his own imprisonment
whether that prison be literal or
metaphorical otho is also tethered to
leash or the limiting emergency
automated servo habit they spend a solid
30 seconds or so explaining how he works
basically a droid that will crush
whoever wears this helmet
if it dies or the captor tries to escape
this will undoubtedly come into play in
future episodes especially with the
eventual otho face reveal
and tempest seeing her assaulter is
still alive they're also kind of
building up tempus to be a killer heck
she's
named after a violent storm she ends up
killing the creature at the end of
episode 4
and she has this pent-up anger so the
question will be whether or not she'll
go through with killing otho when she
finds he's still alive
tempest so hates herself and the fact
she's carrying her assaulter's baby
that she tries to kill herself a baby
otho believes is god's will
we're introduced to this device a master
cell propulsion system
basically a device which collects light
and concentrates it into a highly
charged ray
it's one of the only things that can
take down a necromancer which could be
something similar to what champion
sturgis used to take down one and later
reprogram it into mother if the mathrake
plan to take on mother as the end of
episode 5 suggests
this is likely how they'll do it we also
see marcus retrieve batteries from
ambrose's droid
these could possibly use to power this
device we're also introduced to a woman
named
cassia in polish cassia means pure sue
gets jealous when marcus is given extra
rations by her
so it seems the show is setting up some
future drama here i mean just take a
look at sue's concern when marcus says
he hears the voice of saul
i'm wondering if all this comes together
and ties into marcus's bloody visions
mother is called out of her memory
simulation when sturgis tells her to
rush home
since one of the kids is in trouble this
is further proof that someone has hacked
the system
someone who knows what's going on at the
settlement who do we know that's been
keeping tabs on the settlement
the host or as i guessed an android with
captain sturgis's memory or
consciousness in it sue and marcus find
paul's footprint in the sand
leading them to the end of the episode
the only thing between them and saving
their child
is mother an advanced killing machine so
maybe next episode
we'll see this baby in action
thanks for watching everyone make sure
to like and subscribe and leave a
comment what you thought about the
episodes below
you can also follow me on twitter at
thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much